Stephen crater is a broadcaster and
radio host in the US Stephen thanks very
much for your time this afternoon with
us here on Sky News let me start by
asking will a travel ban prevent
extremism oh well that would be a
question for homeland security I'll you
know as far as protests or banning
Donald Trump from speaking in the UK I
certainly don't think that'll help
measures any I believe in a form of more
ideas of more dialogue not less listen
this isn't a ban it's important to
people understand that there's a
difference from a ban in a 90-day
moratorium on non-residents in the
United States it's important people to
get that right because and they're going
to look at these on a case-by-case basis
you saw that with the green card holders
every single one of them has now been
allowed in the United States so this is
a moratorium put on refugees from seven
specific countries as laid out by Barack
Obama through a bill that he signed into
law in 2015 so it's really easy to say
hey Donald Trump's banning Muslims no
he's not and because he's not of course
he should have a spot at the table to
speak with your representatives there
the green card issue that you know it's
been resolved now but there seems to be
a complete lack of planning in the
announcement over because it initially
did apply to anyone who was a green card
holder in the US did a bit more thought
not go into this considering the topic
well again I'd hate to correct your
language it didn't apply to anyone who
was a green card holder not in the US it
applied to green card holders reentering
the United States going into seven
islamically war-torn lands where these
refugees anywhere else they've been
settled you know skyrocketing rape
skyrocketing crime so as people who have
gone to visit green card holders
re-entering the country now was it
poorly rolled out absolutely was it
poorly planned yeah has that been
remedied yes but it's also not
unconstitutional or unprecedented to
include green card holders in a
temporary moratorium like this so I just
think it's important the media get their
facts correct it's not a ban this was
started this this these wheels were put
in motion by Barack Obama the green card
holders have been allowed into the
country and all of this has happened
before under Barack Obama with the Iraq
freeze under Jimmy Carter in 1980 with
the Iran visa freeze none of this is
unprecedented but everyone wants to
protest and throw fits as you see across
the country and from what I'm hearing
across the UK because Donald Trump's the
big
bad racist but no one cared when
everyone else has done this it's
happened plenty of times Barack Obama
not responding to a real threat it was
when two Iraqi refugees were implicated
in a bomb-making in Iraq that targeted
US troops he then requested a slowdown
in processing new applications this is a
90-day ban it may not be a ban past 90
days but in a 90 day ban on ret anyone
who lives in those seven countries
coming to the US incorrect it's not a
ban and Barack Obama selected these
seven countries as well as the freeze
during Iraqi immigration so we need to
get that right it's not a ban it's like
being expelled from school versus
suspended you can be suspended you can
be right back in school you're expelled
you're out you never get back in that
language matters because you hear people
out there you see people getting
sucker-punched for example today at the
Portland Oregon Airport there's more
violence carried out against Donald
Trump supporters by the way I didn't
support Donald Trump in the primaries
it's important to note but I feel
compelled to defend him by the horrible
behavior that we see on the left both
from the left at large in the United
States and of course their
representatives in the media who use
words that are incorrect or misconstrue
stories because they don't like Donald
Trump it's not a ban he's not the first
to do this and these issues are being
resolved we can have a conversation as
to whether it was rolled out properly
and that's a conversation I'm willing to
have but it is not a ban it's a
temporary moratorium and by the way I
don't know that I would have a problem
on a more long-term ban from people
coming from these countries as we've
seen in the UK as we've seen in Germany
you have 55% of people in the UK who
support a full burqa ban more in Sweden
less than 26% in the United States
because Brits and people in Europe right
now have experienced what's occurred
with refugee mass refugee migrants
making their way being settled in the
countries where they don't assimilate
into the culture and they have rejected
it a lot of Americans don't know what
that kind of hell looks like we need to
be careful we need to be bringing in
people who respect the Constitution of
the United States the rule of law and
who want to become Americans this is a
temporary moratorium but I have no
problem with banning people who want to
come to this country and bring their old
laws with them as opposed to respecting
the new did Rudy Giuliani not and I
quote when he first announced it he said
Giuliani Trump asked me how to do a
Muslim ban legally yeah what do you want
me to do Giuliani says stuff but what
did before it bro refer to it as a ban
well no that's what Giuliani said that
Trump asked about right
this isn't these aren't official
documents it's not like WikiLeaks it's
not like Hillary Clinton's emails
Giuliani is saying Donald Trump said
something there mmmm there's a multitude
of places where there could have been a
breakdown in communication where there
is not a breakdown in communication mr.
McCloud as you and I right now or we're
talking and I'm clarifying that a
temporary moratorium is not a band so I
don't want to be hooked be put on the
hook for words that Donald Trump may or
may not have said because Rudy Giuliani
gave an interview on Fox News I
obviously can't respond to that just
like I wouldn't ask you to respond for
something Nigel Faraj was said that to
have spoken one time in private it's not
a question I can answer
okay Steven and where you are do people
love Trump and you have to we have to
admit that he is in acting what exactly
what he said he'd do to the people who
voted for do they love him and are they
behind him because the protestors you
know in the streets in this country and
also in the u.s. there's a lot of people
getting out there protesting in the
streets are the people who backed him as
animated about this well you know that's
a good question of course the violent
protests that we see right the big
difference between the left and the
right is you look at the tea parties
they actually enacted political change
they primary they're their own
candidates in their own party versus you
know you see the women's March Occupy
Wall Street the protest today at
airports where people are getting
sucker-punched and they're getting
bludgeoned so that's never okay wherever
that occurs I think we could agree on
that I think this I think if you were to
hold the election today Donald Trump
would win by a much larger margin I
think most people went into that voting
booth and said well Donald Trump he's
not Hillary and voted for him there
wasn't a ton of enthusiasm for either
candidate but the left has behaved so
poorly in questioning the results in
questioning the legitimacy of the
president in in creating all these
violent protests or the women's March
where they were wearing vagina hats on
their head and they were talking about
LGBTQA a IP and a silent F and these
fringe social justice warrior leftist
movements at one time only remain in the
deepest darkest bowels of society have
now become the mainstream progressive
platform and so I think you've seen a
lot of Americans who didn't necessarily
support Donald Trump who didn't know how
to vote and now they're just loving to
watch the meltdown the left is being
shown for the
irrational uncle they can't control
their emotions the uncontrollable
irrational mob that they are and you're
seeing more people as you see what
there's approval ratings affair was
there was no violence reported to any of
the women's marches there was violence
aborted the night before by some yet
probably on the left but there was no
violence reported across the world in
those women's marches you're brought
touring everyone with the same brush no
no I'm not I'm talking about it wherever
left is congregate wherever there's a
protester ends up being violent so you
can talk about Woodstock you can talk
about Woodstock 99 you could talk about
the Occupy protests you can talk about
the airport protests the women's March
was by and large peaceful and that's why
I said the women's March where they were
wearing vagina hats going up demanding
abortion up until the day the head comes
out of the birth canal taxpayer-funded
period no exceptions so I would say that
every single one of these protests
whether it's black lives matter whether
it was when you know Bernie Sanders the
Occupy kind of Wall Street movement the
women's March they're not in touch with
everyday Americans who by the way would
have voted Democrat think about this for
a second
you have Michigan the Rust Belt Midwest
unions voters supporting Donald Trump
the left has so far overreached they've
lost Mid Western Union voters you can't
side with the vagina hats at the women's
March you can't side with the black
lives matter and these protesters and
the cabbies unions until you realize at
a certain point you lined up against the
entire rest of America and I think it's
a really rough time for Democrats in the
United States and progressives across
the globe and they better get their act
together because you're going to see
more people supporting people like
Donald Trump who never would have in the
first place hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit calm / mug club
members of your student military or
veteran internet promo code it's less
than $6 a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug oh I just when I feel it I
got a chill like on the inside